Це - гордість української оборонної промисловості.
Міномет "Молот".
До Збройних Сил він надійшов лише два роки тому,
але за цей час вибухав уже чотири рази:
і під час стрільб на полігонах, і на передовій. Що з ним не так?
Міномет "Молот" виробляє київський завод " Маяк",
відомий у радянські часи виробник магнітофонів.
Новітню зброю фахівці підприємства розробили з блискавичною швидкістю:
від документації до появи першого екземпляра
їм знадобилося лише кілька місяців.
За основу взяли радянський міномет 2Б11.
Вартість "Молота" - майже півмільйона гривень.
"Молот" в українській армії - з 2016го, і за цей час унаслідок його вибухів
загинули вже десятеро українських бійців:
у 2016-му - на полігоні "Широкий лан" на Миколаївщині
та у донецькій Новомихайлівці,
торік - в Авдіївці, і ось тепер - на Рівненському полігоні.
Після останьої трагедії президент Петро Порошенко
заборонив використовувати "Молот" на навчаннях
до завершення розслідування.
А самі міномети мають перевірити на відповідність технічним умовам.
Найчастіше українському міномету закидають
неналежну якість металу.
Як стверджують деякі експерти та волонтери,
марка сталі у стволі "Молота" не відповідає технічним характеристикам і
є м’якшою, ніж має бути. Відтак ствол піддається деформації.
Тим часом інші фахівці недоліків у конструкції міномета не бачать
і вважають, що причиною інцидентів, ймовірно,
стало неправильне використання солдатами боєприпасів.
Ідеться, зокрема, про так зване подвійне заряджання,
коли на міну, кинуту раніше,
спустили ще одну, що спричинило вибух обох.
Утім, попри те, що український міномет
поки заборонили використовувати під час навчань,
відмовлятися від нього повністю навряд чи будуть.
Адже, як наголосив директор концерну "Укроборонпром" Павло Букін,
"Молот" не може бути знятий з озброєння, оскільки
альтернативи йому в Україні немає.